Hello everyone! And welcome to TOP 10 FACTS ABOUT MAGNUS CARLSEN
Number 1
In February 2015. Carlsen broke Garry Kasparov’s record
by clocking the highest Elo rating of all time—2,872
In 2009, at the age of 19, he became the youngest world No.1, breaking the record held by Kramnik.
Number 2
When Carlsen trains for a big event, like the upcoming world championships,
it usually involves spending two to three weeks in a place with good weather and the sea.
He and his team of advisers and trainers spend most of the day working on chess,
but also go for long swims, and play basketball and football.
Number 3
Carlsen does not watch many movies
because he does not have the patience to sit through one-and-a-half or 2 hours of screen time, he says.
Instead, he unwinds by watching TV serials. His favourite is Seinfeld, which he has seen multiple times.
Number 4
When Carlsen was 12, his parents took him and his two sisters out of school for a year,
sold their car, put their house on rent, and took the entire family on a year-long round-the-world holiday
which combined chess workshops and chess tournaments.
That year off school meant that Carlsen never really found a taste for institutionalized education, and did not go to university.
Towards the end of that year, Carlsen was paired up to play against Kasparov in a speed chess tournament.
Carlsen played the Russian legend to a draw. He celebrated by eating ice cream at McDonald’s.
In 2009, five years after that first meeting, Kasparov became his coach.
Number 5
A football and basketball fan, Carlsen is also perhaps the only chess player who has bagged modelling assignments.
He appeared alongside actor Liv Tyler for the Dutch designer label G-Star Raw’s 2010 campaign, and continues to be their brand ambassador.
Number 6
At 2 years of age, he could solve 50-piece jigsaw puzzle.
Number 7
He blindfolded beat 10 Harward lawyers simultaneously at chess.
Number 8
Magnus Carlsen is not just one of  the best chess players on the planet,
he's also been voted one of the sexiest men alive.
The UK edition of the women's magazine Cosmopolitan published a list of the "Sexiest Men of 2013"
and amongst the actors, singers and assorted other celebrities is the world's #1 ranked chess player.
The magazine described Carlsen as a "hottie".
Number 9
Carlsen says that if he gets bored by chess, he will try something else.
For me, it’s about playing as long as I’m motivated, as long as it’s fun, as long as it’s interesting.
And as long as that happens, I’m going to continue playing. Whether that’s till I’m 30 , till I’m 40, or 50 going
Carlsen said in an interview with Business insider.
If I quit, I would probably start by studying something that interests me. But I don’t know what ...
Maybe if I didn’t have the talent for chess, I’d find the talent in something else, he said.
And NUMBER 10
Magnus is a big Fischer fan.
He said for the interview for CNN:
If I could choose my opponent to be anyone in chess history,
It would probably be Bobby Fischer at his best.
Because the precision and energy that he played with
is just unmatched in the history of chess.
So, Bobby Fischer from 1970 to 1972.